bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation la compétition économique
mondiale un monde de guet-apens
permanent autant s'y adapter et adopter
l'esprit commando eh bien c'est la
vision que développe mon invité dans son
dernier ouvrage co écrit avec nicolas
moinet un invité aux parcours
professionnels particuliers raphaël
chauvin ci est officier supérieur dans
les troupes marine il publie un ouvrage
paru chez dunod intitulé agir ou subir
l'esprit commando pour muscler votre
projet professionnel ou personnel
bonjour raphaël chauvin 6 bonjour allez
donc vous êtes officier français mais
vous êtes détachées chez nos amis
britanniques chez les rois les ânes
marine et vous avez choisi de nous
parler des neuf valeurs des commandos
alors le commando marine a été créée par
les français depuis récupéré par nos
amis britanniques qu'elles sont c'est
neuf valeurs alors sur des valeurs qui
sont en partie commune aux français et
britanniques puisque nous avons une
partie de notre histoire les troupes de
marine dont je suis issue où a été créée
par les français et les britanniques ont
créé les commandos par la suite pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale donc une
histoire très commune entre ces deux
unités qui son binôme et quelles sont
les qualités qui forgent les tos d'un
des royal marines et hausse d'un
commando c'est d'abord le courage
après l'humilité ensuite le sens de
l'unité
l'adaptabilité
reste aussi le goût de l'excellence
ce qui va plus vous surprendre le sens
de l'humour c'est clair la négation la
joie également il n'y a pas de cours
d'eau triste et enfin la détermination
qui coiffe le tout alors pourquoi vous
avez choisi de transposer ses valeurs
li terre vers le chant civile et
l'économie la compétition économique et
bien aujourd'hui vous parler de
compétition faut pas eu de compétition
économique vous avez parlé de militaires
également comme l'a très bien dit le
chef d'état major des armées aujourd'hui
le cycle guerre paix n'existe plus nous
sommes entrés dans un cycle de
compétitions contestation affrontement
où finalement toute la société se trouve
mêlé et où le monde militaire ne
constitue plus une entité à part comme
jadis il ya des savoir faire militaire
qui mérite d'être fusionnée et transposé
dans le civil mais on va plus loin dans
votre livre c'est pas seulement des
savoir faire c'est des valeurs est-ce
que vous avez vous reconnaissez que dans
le monde économique au monde on manque
en de courage en manque d'humilité
notamment en france et en europe alors
je sais pas si on manque de courage ou
d'humilité en tout cas individuellement
il est possible que collectivement les
valeurs justement qui forment les tos du
combattant n'est pas été encore
conceptualiser ou ou transmises dans le
civil parce qu'à mon avis la notion de
guerre économique n'est pas encore entré
dans notre société et donc peut-être
qu'on n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'il
s'agit bien d'un combat et pas d'une
simple compétition comme on saura donc
du coup évidemment
seul et combat qui manquent et quant au
début un exactement où et vous parlez de
courage effectivement la première des
valeurs et celle du courage alors ces
valeurs là on les retrouve dans votre
livre vous voulez décliner évidemment
alors est ce que vous vous avez le
sentiment que en france par exemple on a
manqué de courage par rapport à certain
nombre de dossiers que sont par exemple
la manière dont les les américains ont
volé le marché du siècle sous les sous
marins australiens alors manqué de
courage je ne sais pas nous avons été
surpris peut-être est-ce qu'un commando
doit être surpris du sommet et bien
justement a pas une question fait et pas
forcément la question du courage en
revanche peut-être que nous ne vont pas
sûr observez suffisamment la situation
peut-être que nous avons manqué un petit
peu d'adaptabilité et peut-être que nous
avons pêché également par naïveté toute
chose qui en fait sont compréhensibles
dans un environnement apaisé et qui dans
un contexte de cons pétitions économique
dure même avec nos plus proches alliés
que demeurent les anglo saxons et bien
peuvent se payer très cher nous l'avons
bien vu en australie est ce qu'on sait
rendre les coups alors je pense qu'il y
a en france une une certaine et
inhibitions à ouidah mouvement est
clairement en terme en termes défensive
que ce soit en termes de l'offensive
économique où l'offensive informationnel
parce que je crois que nous commettons
une erreur nous confondons offensive et
agressions du tout la même chose
l'offensive c'est un mode d'action
l'agression c'est quelque chose qui
effectivement quévillon qui n'est pas
légitime en revanche être offensif pour
défendre ses idées ou ses intérêts au
contraire c'est quelque chose qui est
non seulement légitime mais nécessaire
dans un kart de compétition être
offensifs même vis-à-vis d'un allié par
exemple droit
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
a fait beaucoup de tort aux entreprises
européennes et là c'est vrai qu'on ne
sait pas comment réagir
est ce que les valeurs des commandos
peuvent nous apporter une solution ce
sur la question du droit droit américain
et son extra territorialité les
américains nous ont donné une très bonne
leçon d'offensive justement nous montrer
qu'on pouvait être à la fois allié
puisque en dernier recours je pense que
les français les américains seront
toujours dans le même camp mais
simultanément dans d'autres domaines
peuvent effectivement s'affronter sur
sur ce domaine est ce que nous avons
manqué de courage ce que
est ce qu'on a été préparée clairement à
sa non n'avons pas été préparés parce
que nous avons pêché par naïveté ouais
on est assez démunis vis-à-vis de ça et
qu'est ce qu'un commando qu'est-ce que
un esprit commando peut nous apporter
justement est bien la première chose
c'est comprendre et je pense que c'est
vraiment le préalable tout comprendre
que dans un cadre de compétition
économique et de compétition sociale
également un cadre qui est devenu ultra
concurrentiel eh bien il faut aborder
ses objectifs aborder ces défis comme un
combattant il ne s'agit pas d'un vin
concours en salle ou le meilleur gagnera
non il s'agit bien d'un combat où il
s'agit de prendre l'ascendant donc tirer
le meilleur parti de bain de nos propres
qualités développées celle qui nous
manque analysez également la situation
l'adversaire nous nous comprendre que ce
sont ses atouts mais également que sont
ses faiblesses ses contradictions et
apprendre à agir dessus nice est au
coeur de finalement les jets lité
commando l'agilité combattante on va
parler d'esprit commando ou d'esprit
dire et également sur la belle formule
du général robert qui est vraiment au
coeur de l'action et vous parliez de
naïveté
on a été naïf sur certains dossiers est
ce que pour autant on reste humble
lorsqu'on part à la conquête des marchés
nous les européens alors parfois parfois
les européens manque d'humilité et ça
revient à ce que nous disions avant
parce que nous avons tendance à penser
que parce que nos produits sont bons ils
vont se vendre et malheureusement la
situation est plus compliquée que ça ne
suffit pas d'avoir un bon produit il
faut savoir le vendre il faut savoir
éviter les chausse trapes que nos
concurrents n'hésitent pas à placer sur
un autre chemin pour réussir finalement
à signer ces contrats d'où de nombreuses
déconvenues où mes aventures en france
et en europe occidentale en général
est-ce qu'on a raison à chaque fois de
mettre en avant les droits de l'homme
lorsqu'il s'agit de commercer avec un
certain nombre de pays ce que ne font
pas vous pouvez reconnaître nos
adversaires économique alors la question
est très intéressante je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose malgré tout que nous
devons conserver à l'esprit c'est qu'il
ne s'agit pas de se renier il ne s'agit
pas non plus de renier nos valeurs et je
pense pas qu'on puisse faire du commerce
en dehors de toute éthique puisque
finalement ce serait affaiblir aussi
notre image dans le monde et affaiblir
affaiblir ce que nous sommes donc parler
de droits de l'homme ne pas commercer
avec n'importe qui et n'importe comment
je pense que c'est sans doute une de nos
forces après il peut arriver et c'est
l'effet pervers de ces très bonnes
intentions de départ que par naïveté
nous confondues ont parfois un petit peu
idéologie moral et commerces j'aimerais
savoir comment un livre comme le vôtre
est accueilli dans le monde militaire
si on vous dit mais de quoi tu te mêles
quoi toi tu es un militaire pour te mêle
pas des questions économiques ou pas non
absolument pas je pense que justement le
monde militaire est conscient des
nouveaux enjeux est conscient que les
décisions aujourd'hui nulle part de peut
être remporter uniquement par le feu et
c'est nos généraux nos officiers
supérieurs nos combattants sur le
terrain également sans compter le combat
militaire maintenant ne se limite plus
au feu et s'est élargi dans ces cas de
compétition donc par lyon et donc non au
contraire je pense que les militaires
ont même peut-être compris avant même
les civils la nécessité des fusions des
savoir-être et de certains savoirs faire
d'où la nouvelle doctrine du chef
d'état-major des armées gagner la guerre
avant la guerre exactement 1 donc
évidemment ce type de valeurs peuvent
être intéressante à la fois pour les
militaires mais aussi pour le monde
civil je pensais même plus
qu'intéressante je pense que c'est un
impératif et vivant en angleterre par me
parmi les commandos britanniques depuis
trois ans et demi j'ai pu me baigner un
petit peu dans cette culture culture du
combat britanniques culture du combat
militaire mais économique également et
la fusion entre ses savoir-faire qui
chez nous est une nouveauté est une
évidence depuis longtemps faxon away
donc c'est un train de retard en fait ce
qui est hérissé qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement de reprendre l'ascendant mais
là de rattraper un retard que nous avons
c'est pour ça que ce petit livre se veut
également une arme pour permettre de
bien de nous réarmer
dédicacé par le président du medef votre
bézieux qui est un ancien comment
comment arrive comment donner un effet
qui vend donc pas troupes de marine et
par le rial marine et commandos marine
donc c'est une porte pour rentrer un
petit peu dans le monde du cac 40 c'est
une forte montée d'un rebond du cac40
effectivement le faire au bon dieu le
prouve mais dans le monde économique
également c'est vrai que j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir beaucoup de contacts avec
d'anciens militaires ou y qui ont
particulièrement réussi à s'imposer dans
le monde économique dans le monde
entrepreneurial justement grâce quand ça
leur valeur qui leur ont permis un
management différent et qui leur ont
permis également d'analyser la situation
économique selon des prismes militer
rationnelle des prismes de combats qui
leur ont permis de conquérir des marchés
et de développer leur entreprise un mot
ravages raphaël chauvin 6 sur l'humour
et la joie en quoi l'humour et la joie
peuvent nous aider à conquérir des
marchés est bien la première chose
l'humour c'est un lien ouais l'humour
est un lien et ça permet également de
prendre du recul je pense que dans le
monde économique imecom au combat comme
dans tout finalement dans la vie à
partir du moment où on se prend au
sérieux on est mené sur l'objectif on
n'est plus capable de prendre la
distanciation nécessaire qui va nous
permettre et bien à la fois de voir le
côté cocasse une situation peut-être
mais surtout de l'englobé dans son sens
il arrive à faire nos amis britanniques
très bien les britanniques commencent à
coup sûr d'intervention par une blague
alors il leur est le bruit des courses
intervention pour une blague après ils
rient peut-être un peu moins que le
français au cours de la conversation
mais systématiquement effectivement
l'humour est essentiel et la joie dans
vous parliez et bien la joie c'est c'est
l'énergie vitale qui va nous porter si
on n'est pas portée par la joie c'est
pour ça que les dans l'esprit guerrier
dans l'esprit combattant cette notion
est essentielle eh bien on aboutit n'est
pas la joie c'est aussi ce qui donne du
sens à l'action merci beaucoup raphaël
chauvin si pour voir réponse l'entretien
de l'intelligence économique est
terminée évidemment vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur france 24
points comme au revoir
[Musique]